coping with inflation in argentina is
not easy for people like estela marisa
corta and walmirana
the couple receives two minimum monthly
pensions of around 170 each but it's not
enough each day they go searching for
food in the trash
i thought i was going to age with
dignity i've been working since i was 15
years old the only dream i had was to
have our own home and now look at us
argentina's inflation rate is soaring
and it's having a huge impact among the
countries most vulnerable
economies estimate that the inflation
rate in argentina this year it's going
to be at least 95
a figure that is literally pushing many
people to the streets to try to make a
living and to try to survive these
people here are not only trying to find
food but also bronze and copper or
anything that they can sell so they can
make some extra cash
aramburu says if they're lucky they can
earn around 80 extra dollars per month
selling recyclable materials
but that means being on the street every
day
while medan suffers from epilepsy and
stella mattis has been struggling with
diabetes for years
what you bought for 100 the first month
in three months you will but for two
hundred they're taking money away from
us all the time i need medicines and i
cannot afford all of them
there's over seven million retirees in
argentina and almost 86 percent receive
the minimum pension
a problem in a country that has been
trying to stabilize the economy for
months
what inflation does is that you pay the
new prices with an old salary it happens
to all workers even though labour unions
agree to a 64 salary increase it's not
enough especially when you think the
inflation rate will be close to 100
last week the new economy minister
sergio masa traveled to washington in
search of much needed investment and
financing by multilateral organizations
including the imf
it was just a step further towards
stabilizing the economy a step towards
growth with inclusion for argentina i
believe much more needs to be done the
situation is fragile we have a battle
ahead with inflation
a battle that people like stella marisa
corta and while miranda ramburu have
come to know all too well
perez